[Music]
who fails
doing this you did this to yourself
and now all the other Paris
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie holy crap we
have to break down some of this new
flash footage john wesley shipp in the
90s flash costume in them basically
destroying the universe that he came
from so of course we have to do new
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Easter egg on the video so
we'll start at the beginning I'll just
go through all the Easter eggs
obviously what's going on in this clip
is it's the destruction of the earth 90
universe as the monitor is using the
book of destiny to just completely erase
everyone telling John Wesley ships flash
you had a chance now it's over and
there's basically wiping the slate clean
we don't know exactly why but obviously
this is all leading up to crisis on
Infinite Earths in a future crossover so
when you're Theory crafting about big
grand design I would just lean more in
that direction like things that imply
that we're heading towards something
like that so right now even though the
monitor is coming across like he's the
villain of this scenario that might not
necessarily be the case he might just be
trying to develop the heroes so that
they can face a greater threat like the
anti-monitor someday there's a really
cool thing though is that they pan
across the battlefield you see all these
dead bodies of characters that you
haven't seen in a while so I'll explain
who all these are some of them are
bigger Easter eggs and others like this
right here is the Smallville Green Arrow
costume so it's a fun way to canonize
some of that stuff and say that the
earth 90 Green Arrow looked like Justin
Hartley but if you never watched that
90's flash TV show John Wesley Shipp is
wearing his 90s flash costume but as the
monitor opens the book of Destiny and
starts to erase everything in this
reality John Wesley ships flash is able
to phase to another dimension to escape
the destruction I'm assuming that he
came to earth one because the flash is
the first night of the crossover in our
Barry's on earth one so they're doing a
bit of an infinity war and a crisis on
Infinite Earths Easter Egg with this
there was a character called pariah that
was sort of this Herald of destruction
that the anti-monitor was waving and
destroying all these different realities
pariah was the one that was screaming oh
my god everything is getting destroyed
this is gonna be terrible the person
that did that during the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline was the Silver Surfer
so when they had the Hulk get ported to
the sanctum that was a Silver Surfer
Easter Egg you also probably noticed too
is that as he runs into frame it's the
same type of transition that they use a
visual transition
from the 90s flash TV show and they're
playing the theme song from the 90s
flash TV show so even though they
haven't confirmed that his name is Barry
Allen and he's just an older version of
Barry that grew up on this earth it's
like they're trying to canonize the 90s
flash TV show to the arrowverse but as
you're panning across the battlefield
here you see star girl from the Justice
Society you see firestorm the person
with the white hair could be obsidian
from the Justice Society as well because
he was played by Lance Henriksen he was
an older man he had white hair but there
are only a couple of white-haired
characters in the arrowverse in most of
the bodies are meant to be people that
we have not seen in a while like people
that you won't see during the crossover
so that's why you see both of the Hawks
helmets like they both been killed you
see a red flash costume this is probably
Jesse quicks but it's probably the Jesse
quick of Earth 90 you have to imagine
that all these heroes that are dead are
from Earth an idea it's not like people
from Earth one earth two or three that
we've seen before
there's the Rays helmet I'm assuming
that it's not the Ray that we met during
the crossover from Earth X r.i.p hawks
r.i.p Captain Cold you can see the fur
from his jacket lining here like I said
Smallville Green Arrow costume that's
canon now the other big revelation in
this earth 90's scene is also that there
are more than 52 or 53 earths as
Harrison wells said during last year's
crossover here's that quick clip where
he talks about it from another earth
there are more than 150 - actually I'm
hard-pressed to think of one we're not
these are ascendant I can there's a
fifty third earth
and it's called earth ax that line of
dialogue was more to let you know that
there was a tear about earth where
everything that could go wrong did go
wrong
thank you very much reverse-flash for
making that happen but the whole thing
about the DC Universe is that there
should be Infinite Earths like they're
building towards crisis on Infinite
Earths like the future newspaper that
Barry and Nora keep looking at this
season as the title implies there should
be Infinite Earths but what happened is
is on the first couple seasons of the
flash they wanted to do a new 52 joke
like they have the channel 52 reference
that they use on arrow all the time so
this earth 90 reference blows that out
of the water maybe one of the characters
will make a reference to that if you're
a big comic book reader you probably
remember a little while ago during the
Justice League rebirth arc where the
characters learned that there is
actually a lot of stuff happening
outside of the source wall from Jack
Kirby's fourth world the source wall is
meant to be the end of all existence in
the DC multiverse but the characters
learned that it's really meant to be
this protective bubble around a small
part of what existence really is the
producer said that they argued about
what this scene was actually going to be
because they had a cold open in mind for
the first episode of the crossover one
was this idea that we just got done
watching I think the other idea was
Stephen Amell waking up in the Barry
Allen
iris loft and not realizing that reality
had changed likewise iris kissing me why
is she calling me Barry Allen and is
basically you opening the crossover with
things already having been change like a
big WTF moment like what's going on then
you get the Green Arrow version of that
scene with Barry waking up mid-fight
with Diggle and everyone's like holy
crap but the producer said that is a
compromise what they decided to do was
just turn this scene into a post-credits
scene that would give you an intro and
so the actual first scene of the
crossover is probably gonna be Oliver
waking up in Barry's bed because like I
said Stephen Amell teased that he
actually gets to open the crossover in a
place that he's never been before what
is that place it's probably this scene
with him waking up in Barry Allen's bed
with iris cooking and breakfast
there was an Entertainment Weekly
article where they also imply that
they're gonna replay this post-credits
tag from Supergirl on all the episodes
of arrowverse shows this week so we'll
see a version of this after the arrow
episode tonight then we'll see a version
of it after the
100th episode because they said that
people are coming from all differentials
like not everybody watches all the
different shows and they wanted
everybody to understand what was going
on so they just decided to reuse the
same type of scene with this WTF moment
of John Wesley Shipp running into frame
the really big news tonight is that
we're getting a brand new Captain Marvel
trailer I'll make a video for it as soon
as it posts and we're supposed to get
the Avengers 4 trailer on Wednesday but
I don't have confirmation on that one
Jeremy Renner just implied that we're
going to be seeing footage for it really
soon this week so this week implies
within the next couple of days that
we'll be seeing some of it actually in a
few days so I can't wait not to tell you
what happens what you wait for
everything click here for that new
Captain Marvel teaser and click here for
that brand new flash Elseworlds trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]
you